what about just like on the perimeter
hardest guy you ever had to defend where
you were just like give me the hardest
guy and then the most underrated Guy
where you were like [__] this I don't
think people understand how good this
guy is so my top three I guarded
everybody I guarded Kobe I guarded Braun
um you know I guarded Mike the old mic
you know that Mike yeah that mic I
guarded that mic
um no that's not that Mike is it yeah
that's so that's his last All-Star Game
is it oh okay all right yeah so that
might
um
so obviously all tough to guard right
but the guys that like I was just like
[__]
Grant Hill oh yeah before the ankle
mm-hmm so it was like my first two I was
like when you first got in the league
the first two or three years before the
ankle like you knew he was you knew he
couldn't shoot you knew he didn't want
to shoot
you gave him space and he still could
blow by you yeah he had the quickest
first step like that's what I'm saying
like I guarded Mike's Mike was older but
I guarded Kobe's first step like I felt
like I could get to Kobe you know what
I'm saying his [__] by you it just was
the quickest [__]
um the other person for me was Paul
Pierce and Paul was because
obviously Hall of Fame a great player
but it was something about this game
that you felt like he was guarding them
he was always off balance so you're
thinking like he's like falling but then
he just goes straight up right or you
think he's falling and he just go keeps
going straight you know what I'm saying
so it was just and it was tricky it was
like janky you know what I'm saying so
that would be two and then three was uh
Zach Randolph yo Zebo was Beast Bros and
Zebo was because
when you got done playing against Zebo
you felt like you just had a street
fight yeah he just was he's physical he
on you all game like I used to feel like
I would be on offense and he's he's
still on me I'm like Zebo rotate bro you
on defense like why are you still why
your body still online you know what I'm
saying so those would be the three in my
career that I felt like was just the
toughest what's crazy too we were
talking about the Pacers you actually
were with the Pacers two different times
so like the second because you came the
year after the bro what was it called
the mouse of the palace yeah you were
you were there the year after and I feel
like that was the year
where because Ron didn't play and I
think I do feel like at a certain point
in time Ron Artest might have been like
a top three guy in the league maybe for
like a half a season yeah and then all I
mean as Stephen Jackson say I don't know
if you ever heard him say this but Steve
says he thinks he's the best two-way
basketball player ever
I mean look Peak we're on our tests
was very underrated I don't think people
remember it the right he was so [__]
good dog yeah he was so he was tough
like the [__] he did Miss games
like he had heart surgery played a day
after played the right way towards um
surgery they took the cast off in the
locker room play and this is all while
also kind of trying to have a rap career
for people who don't remember bro he was
yo exactly like it wasn't it wasn't even
like he was just locked in on basketball
all the time he was doing so much of the
[__] and he was that good but to your
point the year that I left they traded
me for Steven Jackson right
um that team I think if they didn't have
the malice in the palace they win the
championship that that's the year that
that's the year in my head that I think
like damn like that Team bro they were
gonna kneel bro they were gonna win 60
plus games for sure we had just won 60
games a year before you know what I'm
saying like they were about to and
and I'm even saying that with me leaving
the team I feel like I was on the team
we meet even better but like that that
team they had everything they had
everything they had everything stacked
they had everything they were going to
win it that year but can you tell me um
what's it like to have Reggie Miller as
a teammate because he's supposed to be
the greatest smack talker ever him Gary
Payton Jordan you know whatever you want
to do but
people say he was kind of like a tough
guy you know like to play against in
terms of he would just talk about your
[__] kids like he didn't give a [__]
yeah I mean he talked [__] but Reggie's
the ultimate competitor
um if you wasn't a Pacer you was like
for real I like for real but I like he
had no other friends on other teams
that's amazing like he had that mindset
um first person in the gym last person
to leave for real not just you know you
hear it literally the first person in
the gym I said as a rookie I used to
bring donuts and orange juice so you
know just say practice is at 11. if I
got there at nine he was already there
bro so I had to like try to beat him
because he was the one that wanted the
donuts right you understand what I'm
saying so I'm like having to be at the
gym at like 8 30 in the morning just to
kind of get through the same time as him
you understand what I'm saying
um as far as on the court like you said
like I said like ultimate competitor he
didn't really he didn't really talk [__]
unless you said something or like
somebody on the bench said something
that's how all them guys were that's how
Mike was that's how Kobe was
um if you give me some ammunition they
just want they just you know like most
times like I always say like when we
playing games and [__] like that which
is kind of dope like you know it could
be it's 20 30 000 people going crazy but
you don't hear it it's like a silence
that we play with you understand what
I'm saying but only thing we do here is
what's on the court and what's on the
benches you understand what I'm saying
so Reggie just waiting for somebody to
hear him take a shot and like oh that's
off you know what I'm saying he like oh
it's off oh just anything to get them
going